I work on the Chrome team.
I work as a Developer Advocate
on the Polymer project.
So we're going to be talking
about Web Components, which is
a totally cool, new technology
that the Chrome team's been
working on for a long,
long time.
Super stoked about it.
Super cool to spread
it with developers.
I want to learn about how
developers are building modern
web apps and teach them these
new practices using Web
Components.
I want to know about how they
architect apps, how we can
bring that back into the
standards process, feed the
engineering team here at Google,
work with them very
closely on that sort of thing,
and have this really awesome
type feedback loop.
And bring that back to the
Chrome team, we can build that
in the standards process and
have everyone then benefit in
the web community from adding
these APIs to the platform.
Hey, guys.
My name's Eric Bidelman.
I'm a Chrome Developer
Advocate.
We're going to be talking about
Web Components, going to
be talking about a little
bit of Polymer.
It's really exciting times
for web development.
You can build components,
define new tags in HTML.
It's going to make your life
entirely more productive than
you ever, ever thought
imaginable.
See you guys there.